Laden with lobster and crab the crew
aboard the freedom comes into the harbor
to unload the morning's catch a job
they've done for decades but could lose
if fishing is banned off holy Island it
would just devastate us completely
there's no way we could possibly Carry
On Fishing from holy Island we would
have to move the boats and all the gear
to other ports and of course the trouble
with that is there are other guys
working from different ports so mean
conflict straight away
and this is what's left of one of this
part of England's oldest fishing fleets
just a few boats including Richard's go
out now
I love to see I've Loved I love the job
it's amazing you get some beautiful days
out there I see dolphins swimming around
you
holy island is already a protected
landscape one rich in biodiversity the
UK government is hoping to create a
number of Highly protected Marine areas
including here where fishing would be
banned they say the scheme would allow
nature to fully recover to a more
natural state allowing the ecosystem to
thrive and that they will take the views
of the local community fishermen and
environmental groups on board
what happens out at Sea really does
affect this entire Community because
once this tidal Causeway floods holy
island is cut off for hours at a time
meaning it's difficult for people living
behind me to commute over to the
mainland
loving father we pray for this holy
Island for our fishermen and their
families inside Saint Mary's Church
prayers are said for the islands
Community some of the fishing families
work in Hospitality the other main
industry on the island the economy is
not just about losing the fishing and
the the money from the fishing it's it's
losing all those other people who who do
really vital jobs in the community there
has been fishing here for
thousands of years we know that it would
be the absolute death null of this
Village
it's just got wrenching I mean I go to
bed at night I can't sleep my stomach's
churning I'm lying there thinking you
know when's this going to end what
reason is it for this it's just
devastating
some Wildlife campaigners say the
protected areas will offer a Lifeline to
the Sea many here are hopeful they'll be
able to carry on and remain part of this
Island's future Emma Hayward Al Jazeera
in northern England